et place maintenant au chaudron et
attention c'est pas celui du stade de
Saint-Étienne elle est là c'est une
joueuse elle est bien placée où elle va
faire une tête pour pouvoir se
rapprocher de ses ex mesdames Messieurs
le but de Daniel
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
allez dernière minute du match avec
l'arbitre qui part mais ah non
apparemment ça serait l'attaque est en
fluo mais qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
tenue de merde attention
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
là c'est fini bravo pas mal c'est mieux
que Daniel c'est mieux
que Daniel pour l'instant mais Daniel tu
as participé chérie c'est super
important que tu sois là allez Géraldine
alors attention attention c'est la
contre-attaque de la joueuse de
l'Atletico modernal partout soleil
élimine tout le monde mais attention
c'est une véritable leçon elle décrocher
le but oui le but de gérer
[Applaudissements]
et
c'est un but mais ils étaient mené 5-0
pour l'instant le meilleur c'est
Guillaume c'est Guillaume pour l'instant
pour l'instant c'est Guillaume
allez Gilbert
[Applaudissements]
je sens que ça va être lourd
attention attention chez vous il est 18h
c'est le milieu offensif de l'équipe il
est en train de cadrer sa première
frappe à nouveau attention il frappe il
va dévisser mais oui ça y est c'est le
but c'est le but le but
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans mon câlins
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va
[Rires]
je crois que tu as perdu une de tes
boules
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on dirait un peu Gainsbourg
c'est vrai un petit gains
pour son âge je trouve qu'il est un beau
corps
pour ton âge
et Gilles t'a donné pour moi tu es
numéro 1
[Applaudissements]
mes chéries
on va se calmer un peu on va envoyer
Benaim
et chérie c'est bien mon Max qui est en
régie oui non mais Max attends il faut
que tu viennes me voir c'est un mec une
légende je l'adore c'est une légende
c'est mon frérot en plus ça fait 10 ans
que je l'ai pas vu rappelle quand on
était à quelle heure ensemble bah bien
sûr puis tu devais me rappeler il y a 10
minutes il y a 10 ans
bien sûr je me souviens de Kemer
[Applaudissements]
tu te rappelles ou pas bah bien sûr je
me souviens tu dansais tu chantais déjà
sur les chansons françaises parce qu'il
est vraiment comme il était déjà comme
je le connaissais il y a 10-15 ans c'est
le même il a pas bougé c'est le frère
parce que non c'est vraiment connu avant
de faire la télé max c'est vraiment
c'est un spectacle
de la radio mais bien sûr mais c'est une
légende j'avais pas reconnu mais moi
c'est le mais je crois que c'est pour
moi je pense que c'est un des trois plus
gros mecs de radio de l'histoire
et c'est tout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça va très bien je suis en pleine forme
on est où tu es toujours avec la meuf
avec toujours la même celle que je t'ai
piqué il y a 15 ans toujours
[Rires]
un truc qui était assez marrant aussi je
sais pas si tu te souviens vous avez des
vieilles pubs à l'époque on était tu te
souviens pas de ça ah la raison c'est
vrai c'est vrai tu as raison c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est avec Flunch exactement
on imaginait le gars qui vient
enregistrer la pub Flunch et box faisait
genre linguisson c'est déjà le comédien
qui vient suis-moi t'a dit combien la
choucroute
dernière fois vas-y
mets-moi un petit je disais mets-moi un
petit peu plus de mots sur les merguez
attends tu vas venir après tu vas venir
après là je suis content de t'entendre
parce que je t'ai pas encore vu mais euh
tu arrêtes arrêtes avec ça je t'ai vu à
Kemer tu combatis ah oui c'est
incroyable il combattait dans la piscine
c'est clair je vais marcher sur l'eau
bah bien sûr on l'appelait Jésus bon on
va appeler je sais
toujours là merci alors
on dirait qu'elle vient faire un truc
c'est pour en direct les Trois Suisses
avec Noël
attention celle qui fait boulette sur
boulette depuis déjà un bon nombre
d'années attention elle va si elle se
rattraper il y a un coup franc elle va
marcher c'est dans la lucarne but
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
Jean-Marie
[Applaudissements]
max ça va on y va dis-moi tu te
rappelles quand on avait
non
tu l'as pécho oui mais je sais pas s'il
faut le dire
c'est pas on a la télé peut-être on est
en direct ou c'est en direct
c'est que ça fait plaisir de t'entendre
avec ton pote Sébastien qui était avec
nous aussi
producteur de musique je sais je vois
tennis exactement 15-2 je sais vous
deviez le battre non ça fait des années
c'était quelqu'un en fait impressionnant
moi non plus moi non ça va toi sinon moi
ça va très bien je sais pas si tu te
souviens de Flunch à l'époque les pubs
bien
tu veux qu'on le fasse là vas-y
allez je te fais
c'est le texte vas-y tu le fais comme ça
comme d'habitude comme la dernière fois
vas-y je t'écoute
on va flasher manger
c'est très bien c'est parfait tu vas
vouloir faire une dernière fois si tu
veux bien Cyril ouais en régie juste une
toute dernière fois si tu peux nous la
refaire mais alors sur la fin sur la
signature si tu pouvais me le faire à
tout petit peu plus en mauve comme ça un
petit peu plus décontracté et ça sera
absolument parfait l'ascenseur la
choucroute
97 francs
ok allez en France
c'était en 96 97 vas-y on va finir
manger léger manger équilibré cette
semaine j'ai fait la choucroute écrire
97 francs on va flatter c'est parfait
sauf que tu as un tout petit peu
accroché contre tu veux que je refasse
quoi sur quoi allez vous imaginez ça
qu'on faisait ça pendant deux heures sur
la photo de la piscine tu veux que je
refasse là on va fluncher ou il te va
c'est dans la boîte plutôt c'est dans la
boîte sinon le reste on va le faire on
va droper d'accord
allez vas-y je te fais juste pour avoir
fluncher on va fin
c'est parfait je suis pas trop nerveux
non c'est parfait c'est parfait tu es
sûr c'est très très bien bah c'est une
toute petite dernière comme ça vraiment
pour être vraiment bien lourd tu es sûr
que c'est ce que votre client
le client est derrière le client est
très satisfait mais tu la refasse une
toute dernière fois
c'est pas mal là pas mal ouais avec un
petit peu moins de sourire
[Rires]
on va faire tuer un peu plus agressif
très bien une toute dernière comme ça tu
me l'as fait un tout petit peu
original
le client dans le monde une petite
dernière un petit peu sexy
on va flatcher bien bravo c'est parfait
tu peux venir
merci
mesdames messieurs il semblerait que
maintenant l'ancien joueur offensif du
club d'Argentine de l'anus va tenter une
frappe du terrain attention c'est une
frappe loup c'est le but c'est le début
[Applaudissements]
je me suis dit il va partir comme ça là
j'ai vu partir j'ai dit mais pour moi il
passe numéro
[Applaudissements]
franchement c'est pas mal
max ça te va toujours pas parfait très
bien ouais t'inquiète on va faire
Castaldi alors
[Applaudissements]
c'est parti mon Machu l'attaquant de
l'équipe adverse qui vient de tomber
dans la surface oui il y a pas de doute
il y a penalty on lui a bien marché sur
la poitrine attention il s'est lancé
c'est le but
de Ben
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et toi c'est la même
[Rires]
en plus on a vu la poitrine
alors il y a beaucoup de gens qui disent
gênants Benjamin Gilles mais non moi ils
ont fait le boulot
on continue la démonstration sur le
terrain avec une joueuse qui a été
pendant un moment donné la doublure de
cheveux de David Guetta attention
élimine tout le monde elle enchaîne les
râteaux et c'est pas la première fois
que ça lui arrive attention fan de dire
oui le but
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
c'est
pas marcher
numéro 3 pas mal
allez
[Rires]
[Musique]
c'est costaud
[Rires]
madame messieurs le milieu de terrain du
FC Rambo attention il arrive il frappe
il arrive oui c'est le but il le met
diamant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis désolé les gars il a tapé très
fort
j'aimerais tellement
moi j'aimerais tellement
après ils sont pas trop le temps non
plus